I am Kanye West the MTV VMAs gave the 39  year old rapper a platform to do  whatever he wanted at Sunday's awards  show i'ma talk and he did not disappoint  addressing the drama surrounding his  famous video head-on including the drums  with t-swift  that's why I called her he was in the  audience during Yeezy speech and  observed some audience members cheering  on Taylor Swift while others booed them  down but the mean singer wasn't there to  take the heat like she did on that  fateful day in 2009 when it all began  Beyonce had one of the best videos of  all time at the end of yeas speech he  introduced his new music video for fade  starring Teyana Taylor can you say body  goals Taylor gave birth to daughter Iman  just eight months ago